alright guys so you probably heard the
whole SOPA thing this whole Stop Online
Piracy Act now I'm all for quitting
online piracy but basically as I'm sure
you know by now this whole thing is just
completely unreasonable to the point of
basically censorship it's pretty much
encroaching upon our own rights of
freedom of speech if this thing were to
pass it would essentially break the
Internet and I guarantee there would be
riots there would be some form of
violence that would break out because
there are thousands and thousands and
thousands of people around the world who
think this is just ludicrous so I
started thinking what if everything in
life was censored all the things we've
grown to appreciate censored blocked
removed taken away what would life be
like if the things we loved were
censored so I made a few skits depicting
various scenarios in which things that
we like our censor to remove from our
lives
enjoy times relax long day
good nerdy book
not cruel
well they tell you the truth and all
this excitement I have kinda lost track
myself I being this is a 44 Magnum
people the yoke you know I
get away from her you
this was censured for being too similar
to Macaulay Culkin's home alone scream
welcome to may we take your order I'm
just wondering what's on the new chicken
sandwich you guys are selling I just
noticed that all the pictures are gone
for your items yes are well
unfortunately all of the rights to the
pictures that were posted were by a
photographer that we can't seem to
contact and so we can't really post
anymore photos that show what we're
selling okay uh well what comes on it
anyway well sir it comes with and and a
side of alright alright alright just
don't worry about it I'll just take a
double cheeseburger that's all I need
unfortunately sir the inventor of the
double cheeseburger has passed away and
we can no longer confirm with him that
we have the rights to sell his product
nevermind don't worry about it I'm just
uh justjust give me a french fry
actually sir the country of France is
suing us for selling french fries so we
will no longer be selling that product
either I'm sorry what
that doesn't even make sense they're not
french fries from france french cut
potatoes just a style of cutting them
there's no point in getting testy sir
French people do whatever they want
french fries are not from France that
that's a that's a style of cutting
french fries it has nothing to do with
fudge people there's nothing I can do
about it sir perhaps you can order
another item you know is there anything
on your menu that is edible that I can
put in my mouth so that I can satisfy
this hunger that I have actually sir it
looks like we just closed but we'll open
up again tomorrow at 6:00 a.m. at least
I think so because some guy named Ronald
McDonald is suing us for using his name
without permission